from a simple corn fart to a
five-dimensional tesseract built by
Indescribable humans from the far future
here's a breakdown of the perplexing
timeline in interstellar relatively
speaking the initial time period in
human history that Interstellar explains
in detail is the first half of the 20th
century according to a series of
dialogue bits throughout the movie those
few decades were rocked by one Global
catastrophe after another which
according to school teacher Miss Kelly
came about largely because people in the
20th century were too wasteful alongside
economic collapse an unnamed form of
blight arose in this period killing off
some crop Staples entirely and leading
to devastating flood shortages worldwide
as a result Earth's many nations went to
war one important enough to become
almost all-consuming economically and
socially yeah well in my day people were
too busy fighting over food to even play
baseball despite the overall crisis in
which Humanity remained for roughly
three decades it also made a series of
important scientific breakthroughs that
ultimately led to its survival in 2019
NASA discovers a wormhole near Saturn
according to the Christopher Nolan
approved book the science of
interstellar following that the military
invents the first Ai and when the food
Wars end they donate the remaining AI to
NASA most importantly NASA sends probes
Through the Wormhole and discovers 12
potentially habitable exoplanets in one
of the opening scenes of interstellar
Cooper and his kids chase awayward
malfunctioning drone hoping to salvage
its valuable solar cells Cooper
identifies it as an Indian Air Force
surveillance drone that has likely flown
aimlessly for a decade daily mission
control and down same as ours 10 years
ago through that and other dialogue we
can confidently place the end of the
food Wars roughly a decade before the
present year when the movie starts after
that Nations rededicated the vast
majority of their resources to Growing
what crops still remained for Cooper and
his family like so many others this
decade was uneventful aside from the
increasing dust storms and blight some
of those few who weren't farming however
made massive jumps forward on behalf of
all of humanity during this time the
secret remnant of NASA launched the
first crude missions beyond our solar
system the Lazarus missions that sounds
cheerful Act on information relayed from
past Pro missions 12 NASA astronauts
left Earth and entered the Wormhole each
headed toward a different potentially
habitable planet their faiths are left
unknown for years given Christopher
Nolan's confirmation that the Wormhole
was discovered in 2019 which Romney in
the film pinpoints as 48 years ago the
present year when Interstellar begins is
2067. at this point a decade into the
age of farming the surviving human
population is in Dire Straits as the
blight kills one crop after another wait
seven years ago okra this year now
there's just corn at this point
everyone's just hanging out drinking
corn beer or whatever it is waiting for
the end in fact the situation is so bad
that the United States many universities
have been reduced to a few small
academies for the most gifted children
only that's why the school principal
tells Cooper that his son Tom is
destined to become a farmer and a farmer
only Tom's sister Murph on the other
hand is a gifted young woman with a
passion for science which helps her
detect and decode the anomalies that
occur in her room these are the messages
from Cooper in the future which you
might have noticed are the beginning of
the movie's potential time travel
Paradox the anomalies manipulate and
move objects in murph's room using Morse
code to send English words and binary to
convey coordinates thanks to these
messages Cooper and Murph find
themselves at the Nexus of their fate
NASA's headquarters in the abandoned
bunker that formerly NORAD but something
sent you here they chose you for who's
they at some point in 2067 Cooper agrees
to join NASA mainly due to Professor
Brand's persuasion and Cooper's
long-standing dissatisfaction with the
life devoid of progress he receives the
tour of their underground Laboratories
from Amelia brand the daughter of
Professor brand who's an exceptional
scientist herself Cooper accepts their
offer to Pilot the endurance a ship
whose mission is to travel Through the
Wormhole review the data gathered by the
12 astronauts of the Lazarus missions
select the single best candidate for the
next human home and transmit the data
back but let's back up some before we
get ahead of ourselves it only takes
days two weeks after Cooper's agreement
to Pilot the endurance that the ship
launches its Crews composed of Cooper
brand romley and Doyle as well as the AI
robots Taurus and case everybody good
plenty of slaves for my robot colony
I gave him a humor setting the first
stage of their mission is to reach the
Wormhole which is still located near
Saturn with the Thruster technology that
you possess in 2067 the journey only
takes about two years although it's long
enough to warrant hypersleep for the
human crew upon waking in 2069 the crew
of the endurance enters the Wormhole
though the occasion is momentous the
trip through the singularity takes only
about a minute once through the crew
assesses their options and chooses to
investigate Miller's Planet first this
is where things start getting weird
we'll be waiting for you when you get
back
little older a little wiser the
expedition to Miller's planet is the
first time in interstellar that the crew
experienced time dilation due to its
close proximity to the black hole
Gargantua every hour on Miller's planet
equates to seven years on Earth go go go
go go go
seven years per hour here let's make it
count when the crew lands they discover
the source of the signal is merely the
wreckage of Miller's ship with the
Explorer herself nowhere to be found it
isn't long before the endurance crew
discovers the reason why the planet's
intense gravity brought about by
Gargantua ensures the water world is
constantly racked by skyscraper size
tidal waves the crew's desperate Escape
encroves complications resulting in
Doyle's death and leaving their overall
time on the planet at around 3 hours but
thanks to relativity it was a lot longer
for everyone else 23 years
four months eight days that brings the
date on Earth to 2092. Murph is now 35
and works with an aging Professor brand
at Nasa to figure out the equation to
harness gravity Tom meanwhile is 40
married has already lost a child to
Earth's increasing dust storms and is on
track to lose another in terms of the
amount of time that passed the endurance
crew's expedition to man's world is one
of the least important pieces of the
timeline the crew doesn't spend long on
man's world and because the time
dilation factor between it and Earth is
insignificant not much time passes on
Earth either in terms of story though
it's pretty important on man's world the
crew finds man wakes him from hypersleep
and begins preparations to establish
Colony on the planet's surface but as
his name implies man turns out to be a
real jerk he leaves Cooper for dead
romley is killed trying to access men's
booby-trapped Ai and man attempts to
hijack the endurance it doesn't go well
for him on Earth Professor brand passes
away leaving Murph the last member of
NASA still attempting to solve the
gravity equation
following the loss of Bromley and the
irreparable damage to the endurance
Cooper and brand are left alone in the
craft with too little life support to
return to Earth the ship is also
slipping dangerously far into the
unsurpassable gravitational pull of the
black hole Gargantua after assessing
their options Cooper realizes that the
only way forward is to abandon any hope
of returning to Earth and instead
slingshot around Gargantua using the
added momentum to reach the third of
their three candidate planets Edmonds
but this comes at the cost of another
massive time dilation
[Music]
the slingshot is successful but only
after Cooper enacts his secret plan to
jettison himself and tars from the
endurance he begins falling toward the
black hole granting brand and case
enough momentum to escape the
gravitational pull and fly off toward
Edmund's planet
though the first two hours and 20
minutes of interstellar are undoubtedly
science fiction they stay within
relatively basic physical boundaries and
are therefore easily digested by
audiences at large then Cooper and tars
enter the black hole and the simple
space exploration narrative becomes a
little less linear
ah
too many fans and critics the sequence
veers a bit too far off course still
whether you love it or hate it it plays
with time in some interesting ways and
ultimately closes the loop on the
interstellar plot both literally and
figuratively Cooper and tars survive
their fall into the black hole and reach
a kaleidoscopic space known as the
Tesseract in which time is represented
as a physical Dimension but they
constructed this three-dimensional space
inside their five-dimensional reality to
allow you to understand it yeah that
ain't working
nothing in the Tesseract works the way
an average person would expect it to but
Cooper and tars are smart enough to
begin unraveling its mysterious
mechanics Cooper manipulates the strings
that line the spaces visible surfaces
and in doing so is able to send messages
to both young Murph and adult Murph the
anomalies that young Murph encountered
when she was 10 were the result of
Cooper's time manipulation in the
Tesseract as was the data that adult
Murph received which allowed her to
finally crack the gravity equation
after being ejected from the Tesseract
transported back to our solar system and
left a drift in space near Saturn Cooper
passes out he wakes up on Cooper station
which he's amused to find out is named
not after him but Murph the doctor at
his bedside informs him that he's
124 years old which presumably puts the
current here on Earth at about 2156 by
this point humanity is completely
space-faring having left Earth and
filled the solar system with an array of
space stations all of them apparently
containing thousands to millions of
people on the station Cooper gets a
glimpse of modern human life which has
time again for baseball and no longer
suffers from ever intensifying dust
storms Cooper and birth are finally
reunited him just a few years older
biologically and her around 90 years
older unfortunately their reunion occurs
just as Murph is about to pass away but
not before the two share a heartfelt
Exchange in which Murph leaves Cooper
with one final purpose to find brand
we're given only the briefest glimpse of
brand before Interstellar ends but it's
clear that Edmond's planet is as close
to Ideal as earthlings could hope for
the air is breathable and the
temperature is acceptable allowing bran
to set up a series of buildings
presumably nurseries to raise the
thousands of fertilized OVA kept on
board the endurance for the purpose of
population seeding all the clues in the
movie point to 2156 as the year Cooper
arrives on Cooper station but there's a
hitch if the slingshot around Gargantua
began in 2092 and lasted 51 years
thereby ending in 2143 we have 13
Missing Years to account for so where
did that time go there are some theories
for starters the film doesn't show the
crew traveling between planets
months-long Journeys which informed
their decision to visit Miller's planet
in the first place Dr man's data is
promising right but it's going to take
us months to get there and Edmonds it's
even further those Journeys may not
account for years but it's helpful to
remember that not every second is shown
on screen another plausible explanation
is that Cooper experienced more time
slippage when leaving the Tesseract or
possibly while inside the Tesseract
itself in the end it may be impossible
to pin down every exact year and date in
interstellar because of how much is open
to interpretation but fortunately that
little detail doesn't in the uh gravity
over the film that's relativity folks
[Music]